Veronica's had many lovers over the
years but you don't really see what's
going on now that the show is more
mature we're really seeing some action
how do you how do you feel about that
you excited about this evolution oh yeah
I feel great yeah it's my it's my job
yeah it's my work and they're freebies
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I don't know what you want me to say it
I mean that Dax and I always you know
collectively say we're married not
buried and when I'm making someone when
I'm making out with someone on a show
he'll often be yelling at the television
to say get we have a clip here from
season four of Veronica Mars let's any
and all that what booty is set up for
this maybe we just go to it right yeah I
don't know what it is so I can't set it
up anyway I love this kind of this is my
favorite kind of television let's take a
look at this clip
[Applause]
mind if I do it's get in line what that
guy yeah who trunks I've seen better
so he does look strong like really
strong hey blue chunks thinking he might
be dumb you don't get laughs like that
former eating ask me how many like
everybody's bringing how many do you get
about his brain then why bother him ask
you
[Applause]